Bitcoin is fundamentally fungible it
doesn't matter which Bitcoin you own
it's going to really matter which nft
you own right because the underlying
value of nft is tied to the content so
and if you know NFL or NBA moment that
is you know that makes the historical
record is the kind of thing that you
talk about gets cited in movies as a you
know a emotion a moment that everybody
remembers you know is is a very
different value than you know my kid
catching a ball in the backyard right I
mean those are very extreme examples but
you take my point
um there's a there is a a market there
that is it is to a larger extent about
the content within the energy so just
owning an nft is not the same thing as
owning a Bitcoin these are just not the
same thing and so I I just want to
ground that and make it very clear that
is the final difference between
non-fungibility and then fungibility
right
um but I think the other point that
you're you're getting at is you know
um Bitcoins specifically right so is its
value inherent to it or is its value
speculative you know and and one thing
I'll just say about that is you know
I've never believed that speculation is
a use case and so I fundamentally think
that one of the less interesting things
about Bitcoin is its price not sneezing
anyone making money I mean go forth
Prosper Etc but you know I actually
think that what makes Bitcoin powerful
um is in part the technology it's the
protocol it's the governance around it
you know it's these kinds of things and
it's the alternative that it presented
to the traditional banking system uh
which which remains an extraordinarily
powerful idea
so um they're just such different things
and and it again it causes me
palpitations to imagine that people
think that you know by getting in the
nft market you're going to make up for
how you didn't get into Bitcoin because
it's just it's just not the same thing
and I mean I think we're seeing that
already right like it not everything is
going for 65 million dollars you know
like most nfts are selling for you know
100 bucks maybe like maybe under that
even like it just kind of depends or
nothing there are many nfts that no one
ever buys by the way to be very clear
you know because they're just not
they're just not great you know so
um it's already a market the challenge I
see with this is already a market where
there's such a high barrier to you know
ownership of what is currently seen as
very valuable and it remains to be seen
what artists and other musicians or
whoever it is athletes you know whatever
will emerge
um that will create that same kind of
value for holders of their of their
tokens so yeah
it kind of makes me a little sad to
think that people aren't doing that
you know all I gotta say just I don't
give investment advice but you know I
just think it's important to to just you
know always exercise common sense and
caution when you're engaging in any
Market you know and think about uh your
think about your upside think about your
downside think about what you can afford
to lose you know and if there but if
there's something out there that is
really meaningful to you you know if
there's a piece of digital art or
there's an athletic moment or whatever
that's interesting and meaningful and
precious to you you know by all means
you know I think it's a wonderful
opportunity to to have a piece of that
and it's something that I find
extraordinarily powerful both on the
Creator side and the collector side